we're here for catwalk for it here which
is a super cool event that Martin and
Sharaf been putting on for years I've
been lucky enough to go the last couple
of years and walk in it so so it's fun
to make the little kid
they're going through so much but they
are always so up
so it's supposed to be fun and I
feel like the more silly you can be and
more fun you can have and the less
serious you can be
the better it is going to be for all the
fans for the kids too
so I'm gonna ham it up as best as I can
it's amazing you know the first year we
started this you know seven years ago we
had 50 people only raised $50,000
tonight we raised $125,000 just in the
live auction in like 20 minutes every
year it's gonna continue to get bigger
and bigger and more people supported and
the more people that come out and see
what it's about and they see the kids
come alive in the stage the more they
love it and it touches their heart and
we were honored to have nature's bakery
as our presenting sponsor this year and
a half Danica here nature's bakery is it
comes
family-owned it has great value
being a partner and sponsoring this
event is hand-and-foot with everything
that they do
they are and I'm so excited they decided
to partner with the catwalk every night
really thankful for everyone you know
for all their support drivers sponsors
we've had so many people come here for
so many years and support us it's been
amazing so I've got to thank everyone
obviously and it's gets bigger bigger
every year and you know the bigger gets
some more kids we can help so we're very
thankful for that it's my favorite night
of the year and I'm just so grateful for
it I'm so grateful to be here